[Music]
shout out to my citizens of Joe Mallya
we've got another question today Joe
bara asks something on my mind is when
will be a time when shaking hands and
greeting people will become normally
situated again never even with the
common cold we've still been around each
other at some point there's gonna be a
time where it's going to be calm enough
part of the society right as a doctor
May 15th I feel it's weird resume all
activities on my desk it's weird cuz
we're so used to coming into the office
and hugging shaking hands something
right and it's just so weird now that we
don't do that anymore
yeah well I saw articles where it was
like doctors like yo I don't think it's
this a yo but uh they're like I said you
know there's a dog I think you shouldn't
be doing there like they don't ever
really see it going back to normal
really so do you think we're gonna bow
like Japanese people I don't think so
cuz it's like Americans are dumb and
we're gonna we're gonna forget real
quick I don't bow for anyone dude I do
but then if you saw what happened like
whenever we had any pandemics before
we're still hugging now you know it's
bad flu was crazy here but people didn't
stop shaking hands and hugging and stuff
about it takes me like two years yeah
we're like to go back I mean remember
after 9/11 those flags [ __ ]
everywhere and then everyone put the
flowers away what's crazy is how they
like separating you guys at the grocery
stores and like letting certain amount
of people in that time because I
remember how Costco used to be when they
were just a regular Sunday before
quarantine yeah and it was everyone
jam-packed together like you're walking
you can't even like get through
Disneyland right now yeah we don't
before oh is it better no no we usually
there's lines and they separate you like
Disneyland
oh I mean in terms of how far they let
you in yeah and finances as far as
Disney it
oh wow lines move faster I have at the
grocery store
I mean business it does move pretty
quick though cuz I was in a big ass line
at Home Depot and I'm like I'll be here
forever and then it was just like BAM
you went real quick it's just the
distance makes it look cute yeah cuz
it's like everyone's six-foot you know I
don't know oh well the question is
really like when do we think it's gonna
be normal
even if okay so we're scheduled May 15
that it's the the quarantine is gonna be
lifted right though even if it was
lifted
I think people won't really get that
yeah it's still scary yeah have you guys
been out and about like that's why we're
here like like so like have you done
stuff like you go to the post office or
you have to go to and then it's like
everyone's just wearing a mask and like
they hand you [ __ ] you're just so
different than like even three weeks ago
yeah it just feels so weird after all
this I'm I'm only dapping up like close
family and friends yeah if you're just
well whatever or you're a fan you're
getting out knuckle-touch yeah oh you're
still I mean like maybe what about
hookups you should ask him too big hey
dude my family member you cousin or some
[ __ ] and like no I'm a fan you like you
wouldn't know that her family no I got a
lot of family oh I got a hookup that uh
he's like pretty chill like he won't
hook up with anyone else so I think
that's right that's that yeah yeah he
also gave me a cool piece of jewelry to
symbolize that he won't do that that's
nice you have a quarantine hookup yeah
yeah from him nah yeah he's taking her
beautiful man I want a diamond on my
ring a diamond ring I know that's why
cuz I don't have a hook up a quarantine
you know the symbol you have many
citizens though that's true but um I
don't I feel like what the hookup
culture it's like you know usually ask
like are you clean and stuff like that
now it's like have you been quarantined
if the girl is dumb and the same way
with the guy if they're big they think
that's rude there's [ __ ] idiot yeah
they are an idiot like you just get your
[ __ ] blood work and all that and you
email them your PDF really why not no
no I'm asking am i judging ask because
then if they lie about it and like
they've had stuff it's on record and you
get something you get test this this is
all the legal things but if they lie
about having something that you just do
them so you just how would they know
that they lied about it they might have
not known well then uh yeah I mean
that's at least if she didn't know
that's how no I mean it's as easy as
checking ID right no you little disaster
hey check their IDs no but if I had to
if someone looked questionable I would
that's an influencer I'd be checking IDs
for sure for what all right yeah I think
about it like Dan Bilzerian well I'm not
here but he has people signing nd aids
before you even get inside his home he's
also his famous for checking IDs because
he won't let you on the boat if you're
over 21 yep over 21 dan Bilzerian has
his people do that before you even get
to him but before in the past he
probably did it himself
when he as he was working up like from
his handful of women and if you were 21
and today's your birthday and you're now
22 withered cucumber you know those MTV
summer beach houses like when we were
growing up in length they would show
these summer beach oh yeah yeah and like
all these people were partying there one
time it was in San Diego and I was 14
but you had to be 18 to 25 if you were
older than 25 you weren't allowed to be
there remember the 18th allowed to be
there hella good did I make an exception
I'm sure they like checked IDs for your
age so I don't know I mean it is MTV and
I mean if you're older than 25 I would
you want a party Lee yeah yeah you want
to go to vh1 room yeah MTV is 18 at vh1
is where it's 35 to 40 to think about
being turned away everything it's an old
old ladies that's so funny 26 is too
cool can you imagine being 26 and you're
like sorry you're old
[Laughter]
that's like uh runway models right isn't
their prime like from like 1420 your
search oh dude that Alyssa and Roseau
chick is like 40 now she look so good
Victoria's Secret is where those girls
go to retire basically all that's the
pageantry do they make the most or I
don't know about now no I think the
Kardashians and that back-in-the-day
though in the runway world when they
were like making like 10 30 million was
just Oliver uh yeah she was like the top
really I don't know anything about that
supermodel era so it goes of your
magazines yeah yeah the girls that
you're jerking off to in those magazines
those are there they have names and
identities I never really notice their
face before I get it I totally good yeah
so what was the NBA of like modeling was
that Victoria's Secret was it no it must
have been like that if maybe they have a
first name now like the fashion shows in
yeah it's fashion fashion like um
editorials like Vogue so Victoria's
Secret was always like those girls are
supposedly the older and thicker models
no that's how it was back then it was
like they actually had a booty they were
like so hot I know but but they were
considered thicker in the modeling world
because in the modeling world you're
basically a human coat hanger yours
would be like 90 pounds and like you're
like you don't have any shape you don't
have a but you don't have boobs you just
hold stuff like that I know it doesn't
matter like all Steve City Myrtle
Monica's high fashion it's not supposed
to be secularized either right yeah it's
more like an art piece they want girls
that look a little bit kind of like
weird alien like right yeah it's very
very skinny and it also like that like
androgynous eye brother before my type
is tall and like super skinny over like
short and I thought you're gonna say
like alien like yeah I like him too like
not like Evangelion yeah I'm actually
beautiful she looks like the kind of
alien I want to invade Earth
yeah frankly that's true yeah but I was
reading an article because it was like I
don't know if it's Tyra Banks or someone
I forget but they were basically like
yeah after you're done with your high
fashion career like Victoria's Secret is
where like you can find words
like that is nuts yeah alright cuz those
were not like perfect bodies in my
opinion but that would there consider
like just more thicker because they have
a butt and they have like cleavage boobs
and some it looks good in lingerie it
probably went to more just traditional
modeling and so did the high-fashion one
was print modeling yeah isn't it crazy
that Gisele butt chins makes more money
in toleration just so when I get it she
does forget it
yeah she makes way to [ __ ] more money
with Tom Brady now she's modeling on
still all over Brazil more people are
watching that then football yeah [ __ ]
yeah so that I get it
well plus he took a lot of detail of
discounts to play with the Patriots over
the years but still man holy [ __ ] that's
crazy because she makes that much money
because football is just America and
fashions the worldwide but people always
say old ladies can't make that much
money who said she oh you know lady
she's like 40 oh that modeling at 40 is
is is like she's she's a grandma in the
game that yeah I guess but seeing with a
athleticism like say with Tom Brady I
know he's 40 years old really what do
you usually buy besides it may be their
life and merchant like some other stuff
he doesn't watch you know yeah modeling
it's all about spending money like
that's they if I have way more money in
that than football they for sure have
all any of that yeah yeah
exactly and that's because we don't know
about all the fantasy football dark
money out there I'm sure but it's like
yeah [ __ ] billion
I've spent money on her billion did you
know that six billion dollars dark money
well of fantasy football in fantasy
football that is like off the books and
like that considered sport betting or is
that separate so it's like um uh you
know how the NFL has their NFL calm and
like like their other Yahoo fantasy all
these other places well there's a lot of
off sites where you can spend money it's
not regulated and there's it's not sport
betting this is separate you know what
it's sport betting but it's fantasy
sport betting so fantasy sport betting
by itself separate from Vegas separate
from just baby no no I'm talking about
Vegas and stuff but but off the book
[ __ ] like the whole like all that stuff
like the black market for for fantasy is
six billion that's what the NFL
estimates you Wow
after this guy's question speaking of
Vegas when you think Vegas all pop out
that's what I've been waiting no you're
the mayor yeah but the governor's not
letting him yeah but still it's the
mayor the mayor is like basically saying
let us be and she said it she was like
let us be the control group like just
letting people go back in Siena and the
Prince showed me footage yesterday of
because he does a construction out there
and he was recording all of it it's a
ghost town yeah there's nobody there
we live in a representative Republic
that Mayor was elected by her
constituents in the airport speaks for
her people and if that's what she says
then that's what they think over their
control there was a lady there yeah okay
oh I know the former mayor then he I saw
our AmeriCorps said no no no of Las
Vegas he is the he was attorney for the
mob there and he became the mayor of Las
Vegas and I saw a whole podcast with
them it's not like that Ozark lawyer
chick yeah how quickly when these places
do open up would you consider going
there like wait there's gonna be a
second wave yeah I mean they talked
about it wait to make sure if anyone's
sake but I don't want to miss out on the
deals yeah so I might go while I'm
covered up you know I'm enjoying it
so bocas was my first time using my em
life forward so I got the credit card
and like I said my first time using it I
got two free night stays at MGM Grand
and we booked it for our anniversary and
this was back in January we booked it
for May now we had to cancel I'm like it
was the free it's a free [ __ ] good deal
use it I don't know because this has
never happened before when it comes to
like who's gonna be the first and I am
the guy who gets drafted into war and
then like they breach a room and like a
blast and think oh [ __ ] breach and then
and then the guys like okay go on in and
I'm like yeah go ahead dude I'm going in
next yeah you're all [ __ ] honest how
much you
that's me when it comes to Vegas I'm
gonna let a couple people go it's like
you at the ball a waterslide exactly so
there's this natural water sign it was
like 25 foot tall and it was super crazy
like it looks like you're what like
going down a waterfall and he had to
watch like two local boys do it and then
me and Jess Lozano I went before you
okay before after Jess no I went before
you I won't before you both leave I
wanted to see the locals go down though
because the locals swore that it was
safe and I was like okay but is it ever
seen a guy like Steve would send the
ladies out you know the sighs I know but
I remember even having to watch people
go down first that's what I'm most
concerned about though is that I'm like
yo because these local boys are like
[ __ ] five foot six and [ __ ]
I'm like has any one as big as me going
on this thing I know i yeah guys will
you go down right now and lecture it so
they both didn't I was like okay and
then Nicky's think I want to go and I
think I'm gone before you're going no
[ __ ] way yeah yeah why I don't want
to have more fun than her before she got
that far